hey I do want to mention that there is
an independent Republican candidate
named Evan McMullen who is a former CIA
official opposes Donald Trump and is
running for uh president recently worked
on policy developments with the House
Republican Conference yes he has already
missed the ballot access deadlines in
dozens of states but he is a Mormon and
he could actually make an impact in Utah
and we've already talked about Utah
being one of libertarian Gary Johnson's
strongest states currently it's Trump 37
Clinton 25 Johnson 16 in Utah this is
the best state that Gary Johnson has in
terms of his libertarian party candidacy
if we add McMullen to the Utah ballot it
could take some from Trump it could take
some from Johnson and importantly
fourteen percent of Utah voters are
currently saying other they've not yet
picked a candidate if a lot of those
individuals Utah of course the most
Mormon state in the country could have a
strong rallying effect behind the Mormon
candidate McMullen that could actually
give Utah to Hillary Clinton and when
you think about it that the Gary Johnson
support in utah by mormons doesn't make
that much sense gary johnson is
pro-choice uh and a lot of the the
people Republicans in utah that are
supporting johnson are doing it because
if they're strong dislike of Trump but
given the option of an anti-abortion
candidate like McMullen they could very
quickly move away from gary johnson and
you know we know that mathematically
utah by itself is very unlikely to swing
this election but Trump advisors have
been very clear that Trump needs at
minimum all the states Romney won and
that of course wouldn't get him a
victory and then he needs to pick up
something else if he loses any romney
states it is very unlikely these going
to have a good november eighth yeah this
is uh makes utah a bit more interesting
than usual to look at right and uh i do
you like this guy in general I mean of
course you pick him over Trump yeah uh
not really I mean yeah he's just some
guy I don't think he's particularly
qualify
I think that this is sort of a last
ditch effort and as I mentioned he can't
even get on the ballot in many many
states it's mostly a non-starter but it
would be sort of poetic in some way if
he ends up taking what is often one of
the most read voting states and actually
helping Hillary Clinton win that state
it would be incredible yeah uh and that
it would be basically the nadir effect
just on the one in one state um I I'm
sure Hillary the Hillary campaign is
thrilled about this my prediction is
we're not going to talk very much more
about mr. McMullin but at least we've
gotten it on the record Louis that he
does exist and in Utah he might be able
to make a difference if he makes more
news we will absolutely tell you